au delà de ma satisfaction bien entendu
pour pour une normandie qui m'a vu
naître et qui m'a vu grandir
j'ai toujours porté la réunification de
la normandie dans mes convictions
politiques mon projet politique donc je
suis très heureux qu'en effet on soit en
capacité de pouvoir construire cette
réunification en même temps bien entendu
il faut aussi avoir la victoire modeste
quand on gagne en effet de 4500 vois ça
vous oblige
d'autant plus à avoir en tête deux
événements qui pour moi reste majeur le
premier c'est que même si le front
national n'a pas confirmé au second tour
le front national continue à progresser
de scrutin en scrutin et donc il faut
bien avoir en tête qui alla pour
l'ensemble de la classe politique
une vraie un vrai message que notre
compatriote les adresses d'élection en
élection à chaque fois les parties du du
front au dessus du moins du champ
républicain évoque à chaque fois qu'on
tire les leçons et en fait en vérité on
ne dira jamais assez le problème message
et le second message c'est bien entendu
d'avoir une présidence qui souhaite une
présence la plus ouverte possible pour
rassembler le plus largement possible